こんにちは。
まぐまぐイベント事務局です。
[EN]8月22日（土）、『週刊 Life is Beautiful』の[/EN]
テーマは、
「第2のエヌビディアはどこだ？
──エーアイ×メタトレンドで読む次の10年」
ChatGPTの登場以降、エーアイは私たちの仕事や生活だけでなく、産業構造そのものを大きく変えつつあります。
今回のウェビナーでは、
ChatGPT以降、世界はどう変わったのか
エーアイ革命はこんごどこへ向かうのか
「第2のエヌビディア」はどこから生まれるのか
エーアイ時代に求められるスキルとは何か
最前線の人々は、エーアイをどのように使いこなしているのか
といったテーマについて、中島さんとKEITOさんにじっくり語っていただきます。
投資に関心のある方はもちろん、エーアイが社会やビジネスをどう変えていくのかを知りたい方にもおすすめの内容です。
【開催概要】
日時：2026年8月22日（土）13:00〜15:00
参加費：無料
開催形式：Zoomウェビナー
【主なトピック】
ChatGPT以降、世界はエーアイ革命でどう変わるのか
「第2のエヌビディア」はどこに現れるのか
エーアイ時代の最先端人材が使いこなす「Claude Code」とは
エーアイエージェントは私たちの働き方をどう変えるのか
お申し込みはこちら
皆さまのご参加をお待ちしております。
まぐまぐイベント事務局
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。